with hitman agent 47 out now let's take
a look at five things you probably
didn't know about the movie based on the
hit video game series the movies stunts
and fight coordinators Jonathan Eusebio
and John Valera created contrasting
fight styles for agent 47 who's played
by Rupert Friend and John Smith who's
played by Zachary Quinto they based John
Smith's technique on traditional
Japanese karate and some kickboxing and
gave him a haymaker punching style and
to give 47 his own distinct style they
trained friend in Malaysian steel at and
Filipino martial arts as part of his six
months of training friend also learned
boxing some judo and Kung Fu and Krav
Maga which is a self-defense system
developed by the Israeli military friend
also did intensive training with the
movies armaments team to make sure he
was comfortable with agent 47s signature
weapon the Silver Bullet pistols he even
took them home with him to practice and
according to the actor by the end of his
training he could take the gun apart and
put it back together again with his eyes
closed
however friends still managed to injure
himself on set when he fired his gun
into the ground by accident and a blank
cartridge bounced up and hit him in the
head despite being hurt friend kept
filming and the take actually made it
into the final movie but that's not the
first time the actors got caught out by
a gun on set when he was filming
homeland a stray bullet from someone
else's gun accidentally hit friend in
the neck speaking of homeland while
filming hitman agent 47 Hanna were who
plays Katia van Dee's in the movie was
pretty persistent in trying to prize
spoilers about homeland as a Rupert
Friend who plays CIA agent Peter Quinn
on the hit TV show but friends managed
to keep quiet about the show's future
twists and instead had fun teasing his
curious co-star during the shoot
friends made a deliberate decision not
to watch the first movie adapted from
the Hitman video games which was
released in 2007 friend avoided the
movie which starred Timothy Olyphant
as he didn't want to be influenced by
someone else's interpretation as
character agent 47 instead he relied on
the video games and was particularly
influenced by what he describes as the
deadly graceful way agent 47 moves in
the 2012 installment absolution after
experiencing the games friend also felt
strongly that the movie should put more
emphasis on the elements of stealth
cunning and disguise and worked with the
stunt team to include forty-sevens
trademark gujrat or fiber wire to get
agent 47 signature look right the movies
costume designer visited many design
houses in New York as well as Germany
were part of the film was shot but in
the end to get the classic well cut
outfit she wanted she hide a tailor from
Madrid who flew out to the film set to
create the suit from scratch
10 black suits 10 white shirts and 10
red ties were all custom made from
finely woven cotton for the shoots and
rupert friend said that when he put them
on he felt like an assassin who've been
paid millions to do his job now let me
know in the comments below what other
video games you'd like to see on the big
screen and what's your favorite video
game movie and why by the way my next
video is going to be a movie review of
the horror sequel sinister 2 and if you
enjoyed this video do please share it
hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for more things you didn't know as well
as movie reviews and interviews thanks
for watching yippee-ki-yay movie lovers